hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
clash between adulthounderson and paul
charles morphy this is game six and if
you've been following the match so far
uh anderson took the lead by winning
game one then game two ended in a draw
and then game three ended by morphe
winning uh equalizing the match and then
uh in game four morphe also won the game
so in game five morphe took another
victory and now we are in game six so
let's see uh what understand will two uh
we've seen in the previous uh video
where he had the black pieces he tried
the scandinavian defense and it was a
really really funky game but this game i
think is the the absolute most
complicated so far it's super enjoyable
we're going to have two really awesome
positive video moments uh so and the the
opening in this game is really really
cool uh so let's see wha what's
happening here
and uh understand now with the white
pieces opens with a3 and this is also
known today as the anderson's opening uh
and i will tell you why uh because it's
not you know i know you guys i know what
you guys are thinking obviously his
initials are a a and here uh anderson is
making a joke by opening with the a pawn
uh although that's a very good guess
that's not the reason he's actually
trying to play uh the sicilian defense
with the white pieces and he's trying to
mimic uh one a very very uh certain uh
well opening system that he faced in the
1851 london tournament that we've
mentioned uh so i'm gonna show it one
more time these are the standings of the
1850s no not the standings but the cross
table uh of the 1851 uh the great
tournament in london that adolf anderson
won and you can see in the finals uh he
faced off against vivo marmaduke and he
defeated him with a with a result of 42
and one of those games uh is the
great victory of marmaduke over anderson
where marmaduke had the black pieces and
he employed this line of the sicilian
defense uh in case you want to check out
this game first before continuing this
video just you know to get better
acquainted with what's happening in this
one i will put a link to it in the
description below it's just the pgn on
chessgames.com so you can just check out
the game to see what marmaduke was doing
with the black pieces so you will better
understand what anderson is trying to
achieve here with the white pieces so
that's why a3 and that's what he was
trying to achieve here
to get
that sort of an attack against morphe
because it was a really really awesome
attack with the black pieces so here
he's basically trying to do it being up
a tempo as he has the the white pieces
so maybe uh you know and of course he
knows morphy will grab the center and
everything so on so uh he he's trying to
get that kind of a position but okay
let's check it out we have e a3 uh
morphe grabs the center of course with
e5 we have c4 by anderson knight to f6
and the knight to c3 and now uh morphe
playing black as if he were white and
now strikes in the center like it was a
white playing against black and black
had the sicilian defense we have c
captures on the e5 knight captures now
e3 and bishop to e6 now by morphe we
have knight to f3 attacking the pawn
here and bishop to d6 defending morphy
always develops his bishops like this or
on d3 and on e3
we have bishop to e2 and now morphy
castles and now we have d4 here and this
is not the only game where anderson will
try to get this set up with the white
pieces he played a3 in three games
against morphe this is the first one of
them and uh it's uh well we can say that
it is now as of this moment that we have
a completely new game so already as of
move eight uh in the other games he he
also tried the for once and he tried
castling once but here okay we have d4
uh morphe captures on c3 with b captures
and now e4 chases away this knight
knight to d2 and now f5
so anderson doesn't want to allow f4
here so he plays f4 himself uh and in
that game that i've mentioned uh you
know white tried something like rook to
f6 then rook to rook to g6 going after
the black king you know with the colors
reversed but here
it's as if morphe was starting to enjoy
the madness and he said all right let's
go for it let's play g5 and now anderson
basically got what he wanted he he he
really wanted uh you know a very
complicated attacking game and he
definitely got it if morphe wanted to
play you know a normal move or something
he could go for something like he
captures on f3 alpha song and after
bishop captures just knight d7 you know
continue playing the game the white king
is still in the center of the board you
know if if you don't capture on b7 uh
we're gonna play c6 if you capture we're
gonna play rook to b8 and get even more
development in while the white king is
still stuck in the center so that's one
way to do it and another also very
interesting way instead of this g5
madness movies just queen to h4 g3 queen
h3 so also very much playable for black
but like i said it's it's as if morphe
is really starting to enjoy the madness
so here morphe plays g5 uh and now
bishop to c4 by anderson uh going after
morphy's bishop here if you defend with
the queen anderson will just bring
another attacker with queen to b3 so
morphy trades here we have knight
captures and now g captures on f4 morphe
now opens up the g file uh planning to
play at some point probably king to h8
and then bring the rooks over to the g
file e captures on f4 and now queen to
e8 and this is a very very uh nice idea
by morphe he wants to bring the queen to
c6 and anderson never really wants to
capture here uh well you're just going
to improve black's position in the
center and well if anything this knight
should come to e5 so here finally
castles by anderson and now queen to c6
going after the knight here and it's a
really really uh difficult position to
analyze because of course uh you don't
capture the bishop here everyone of
course would play knight to e5 i mean
who wouldn't but knight to e5 is so
super complicated i'm just going to show
it very briefly uh it was not played in
the game but if knight's the e5 we're
going to capture on c3 attack the rook
here and then if rook to b1 now we're
going to capture the knight so bishop
captures we're going to play d captures
now white gets a pass pawn knight to c6
developing
a piece preparing to bring bring the
rook center game now queen d5 check king
to h8 and now bishop to b2 seems uh
like a great move if the queen moves
then this is going to be really
problematic uh but black now has this
rook 8 d8 move and here this is
basically where the fun starts and you
have to analyze it all the way to here
to really see what's happening here so
now white will move the queen but of
course you're going to attack it once
again and only after queen captures on
b7 now you deliver queen e3 check for
example king h1 and now queen back to b6
and now you got the white queen out of
the game and well this uh
uh e6 check will not uh will will not be
deadly so we're going to play bishop day
one first uh if of course the queen is
captured then we can already have a rook
on b7 but black has nothing better and
then if captures captures uh now we're
gonna play king to ga to not allow any
any checks here and now for example rook
captures on c7 if we want to play uh
play like this you know be up a pawn
it's definitely playable uh but it's
super complicated and you have to see
way way ahead uh which you know
shouldn't be a problem since they
they're playing clocklist so you can you
know take as much time as you want on a
move uh but you know it's not a very
gentlemanly thing to do so here anderson
plays queen to b3 instead now threatens
a lot of very nasty discoveries the king
is on g8 and morphy plays queen to d5 he
doesn't allow any discoveries rook to b1
now putting pressure on the b7 pawn uh
but uh just b6 by morphe so not even
not even allowing that uh and now again
uh knights the e5 is always an option
but anderson simply doesn't enjoy this
move it's a move that you play if you're
leveled in the in the match but morphe
is already uh enjoying a pretty big lead
uh so anderson has to you know go go for
for everything so queen to a2 he wants
to unpin here by playing queen to e2 and
the guard the knight all the way from
here
c6 by morphe getting rid of his
weaknesses and now preparing to develop
the knight via the the d7 square so
queen to e2 now the knight can move and
just knights the d7 now morphy can
finally start bringing the rooks into
the game
knights the e3 attacking the queen again
for some reason anderson does not like
this e5 square i mean how how many of us
would just place the knight on e5 as
soon as it was possible but not anderson
uh he is he's a true gentleman
knight the e3 attacking the queen queen
to e6 and now c4 now slowly uh but
surely grabbing more space in the center
and asking morphy what do you play here
so morphe continues development uh
knight to f6 and now rook the b3 a very
nice rook lived by anderson now the rook
can join the attack with rook the g3
we have kinked the f7 by morphy he says
all right my king will be safer in the
in the middle of the board and i
probably want to double up my rooks here
on the g file we have bishop to b2 uh
and now morphy knows that anderson wants
to play d5 bust open the position
completely then the bishop comes alive
and it's just complete madness and
morphe respects anderson he knows how
strong he is and he plays rook a to c8
so now if the d file uh the c file opens
up then uh at least he will have a rook
very nicely placed on the c file
but it's uh it's a question whether to
do this or not because if you go with
the d5 right away which is definitely
possible uh c captures on d5 we're going
to play bishop captures on f6 here and
now after d captures on c4 attacking the
rook we're going to play rook to b5 and
now the king cannot
well the queen can't capture because
rook captures on f5 wins the queen so if
king captures we're gonna play rook
captures on f5 either way and now the
king has to move and now well anderson's
position is better uh he can play for
example rook to h5 rook to g5 and you
know just continue pushing so whether he
would be able to win this it's hard to
say but it is a very enjoyable position
it's uh also uh well we need to uh we
need to note that black has a past c
pawn and the past e pawn so black does
have counter play here but it's one of
the possibilities he doesn't go d5 right
away he first prepares it with king to
h1 uh see this is 1858 and anderson
knows the rule of attacking you have to
play the prophylactic king to h1 before
you start the attack because black has a
dark square bishop there's a queen on
the board so you you're going to run
into a check at some point so here we
have rooked the g8 by morphe and now
finally d5 attacking the queen here so
morphy captures and now
do you capture here or do you capture on
f6 now it's a little bit different if
you capture on f6 now now morphe would
capture with the queen and now after
knight captures and d5 attacking the
queen queen to e6 now you could play for
example rook to h3 and it's again a very
very active position anderson is
definitely better here but he decides
for uh for a bit of a different line he
plays c captures on d5 first uh
attacking the queen and the knight and
now
what do you play here well you could
capture with the knight the d5 square is
defended twice but then you allow queen
to h5 check you've just removed the
knight from here and you know it's uh
starting to look very very ugly not not
something you want to do
so instead after c captures on d5 we
have queen to d7 by morphe and now
knight to c4 this is now played with
absolute precision now the knight is
finally coming to e5 uh and it's gonna
be very very unpleasant for morphe we
have king to e7
uh and now not knight to e5 right away
but first bishop captures on f6 king
captures on f6 and now we reach the
position where you really need to know
what to do it's actually the position
from the thumbnail maybe i'm going to
use it in the thumbnail this time so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for
anderson while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding the
incredible queen to be to check this is
what anderson played and this is not the
winning move the winning move is
actually rook to h3 and we're going to
briefly show it because it's uh
well it's such a such a fun move to play
and it's very weird that anderson did
not find it because anderson is a master
of uh silent rook moves if you've seen
his rook eight to d1 move and you know
which game i'm talking about then you
know really congratulations on knowing
your your chess stuff
but here rook to h3 is just too strong
uh because you're threatening rook to h6
this will come with check and the knight
is already attacking the bishop here and
there really isn't all that much you can
do to defend this uh if you play
something like king the g7 now trying to
get out of the way we're just going to
play queen h5 now threat and queen
captures here if king h8 now the queen
covers this but not just knight captures
and d6 and if queen captures will
deliver checkmate so that's not an
option and another thing after rook to
h3 you could play something like rook
seat uh f8 uh trying to you know
block somehow the the squares here then
like we said we just delivered this rook
to h6 check and that's it if you if you
move the king then rook captures here
and if you play rook to g6 which of
course is a possibility then you can
play anything basically queen to b to
check now he's a very strong queen to h5
is very strong and you know
black just falls apart
but it is not it's not a very very
simple to find for example queen to b to
check you have to play something with
the king let's say king the e7 uh and
now okay now we can pick up this pawn
for example rook captures on h7 rook to
f7 and now you get a disposition and uh
we we know that it's winning but it's uh
it's a lot to see uh once you once you
uh realize that nothing else is winning
here then you play rook to h3 no
questions asked but anderson played
queen to b to check and while this is
all you know still good for white it's
not as strong because now morphy plays
king to f7 and now anderson brings the
rook to h3 but now you don't have rook
to h6 with tempo and uh well you you're
not going to be capturing an h7 because
morphe just plays rook to g7 so here
morphe is still very much in the game uh
and it's hard to find uh hard to find a
good continuation here for
understand because if knight the e5 with
check we're just gonna capture and after
pawn captures the d5 pawn falls and
black uh black now well very easily
holds this there's really nothing to
worry about here from uh from white uh
if rook captures on f5 it's not a
problem king g8 and we're still
perfectly fine here i mean uh we we also
enjoy a past e pawn here so not much to
be uh worried about uh so instead after
this rook the g7 move we have queen to
d4 anderson centralizes the queen now
knights the e5 is coming and the queen
will be guarding the d5 pawn but now
king the g8 morphy says all right knight
to e5 is now no longer an issue because
it doesn't come with uh check and
connecting with the queen so rook the h6
by anderson threatening to win the
bishop here and now bishop to f8 so very
nicely the defending the the position uh
and now knight's the e5 uh yes you could
play this attacks the queen positions of
the knight very nicely then queen to b5
you move the queen with tempo attack the
rook here then you pick up the pawn on
a3 and then you start you know advancing
your
queen side pawns and well black black
will be better here so anderson uh keeps
the knight there plays d6 now now this
is a beautiful pass pawn already on d6
and now morphy plays rook to f7
attacks the rook here on h6 we have rook
back to h3 by anderson and now morphy
plays queen to a4 that with a double
attack on this knight here uh sorry with
a double attack on this knight here and
anderson uh has one move that he really
really should play uh and that is rook
to g3 check we're gonna show it but it's
super complicated in the game rook the
c1 just defending the knight was played
but rook the g3 check if well bishop to
g7 basically only move and now we play
rook captures on g7 rook captures on g7
and now queen to d5 check we un pin here
king to h8 and 95 and now we have uh all
of the
tools that we need to continue fighting
here knight f7 is an idea d7 is an idea
uh there are so many ideas here and well
if you play rook to f8 stopping knight
f7 we're gonna play d7 both of the
knight and the queen are nicely
defending this and now if we're back to
d8 and now we're going to play queen to
e6 threatening to
play a queen to e8 with check and after
black finally grabs this now we don't
capture it but rather play queen to f6
check and we now have a perpetual now
you can't play this because then you
lose this rook and if king the g8 we're
gonna play queen g5 check and now we
repeat uh if you go here then we're
gonna capture this with check and then
it's white who's better so you have to
settle for this checking g8 queen g5
checking h8 queen to f6 check and so on
so here we would have a drop by
perpetual checking
so after queen to a4
rook the g3 is best for anderson but
perhaps anderson calculated everything
and saw that it only yielded a draw
and he had to play rook to c1 to
continue the game going uh so rook to c5
by morphe now again uh uh
well allowing this rook to g3 but now
it's a little bit different anderson
plays it we have bishop to g7 and now
you can't really play this because now
after rook captures rook captures you
don't have d7 the knight is not on e5
and that's uh well a huge difference
because the queen and the rook guard the
d7 square and you can play knight to e5
because the rook on c1 is hanging so
this is very much different so after
this bishop the g7 move anderson played
h3 he created some breeding room for his
king
and now
well again very very complicated morphe
has to play uh h5 h5 is the move you
should play and now the point is after
rook captures on g7 rook captures on g7
and rook to c3 uh you can simply move
the king king to h7 and it's not a
problem you do not allow white to pin
your rook here
uh so that's that's uh one
one of the possibilities uh and uh
another thing is that well that that was
not played in the game king the h8 was
played in the game right away but now
anderson has a beautiful beautiful move
that really allows him to take
initiative and you know win the game so
feel free to pause the video for a
second time and win the game for
anderson while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
spectacular queen move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen captures and g7 i'm only joking no
that would be too cool unfortunately
that's not the move
the move is actually queen to d2 yes
just retreating with the queen now that
the king unpinned and the rook is no
longer well on the same file as the king
bishop captures on d4 is the threat so
here anderson played rook captures on g7
but the correct idea is actually queen
to d2 and it's super super strong uh now
there's really not all that much you can
do here with black point is uh if you
play something like rook captures on c4
now yes you win a piece but now we just
play rook captures queen captures and we
advance the pawn to d7 and there's no
defending this uh whatever you're trying
you could try queen to f1 king h2 and
now there's there's no stopping this if
rook to f8 we just bring a queen into
the game black has to give up the rook
and that's it we we win the game bishop
f8 queen captures and f8 is checkmate so
that's one way to do it and after queen
to d2 if you don't go for the knight you
could bring back the queen of course you
have to cover d7 and the e8 but you know
knights the e5 is coming so maybe not to
d7 so the knight attacks the queen we're
gonna go all the way to e8 but still 95
incredibly strong now this rook is
attacked this rook is attacked and well
what do you play if you capture here we
could deliver check queen captures now
and uh let's say bishop captures on e5
just f captures an e5 and the two pass
pawns are now completely winning for
white point being that this pawn cannot
be captured because white now delivers
checkmate and that's it you have to
start giving up material and uh anderson
wins the game however after this king
the h8 move uh anderson did not find the
the subtle queen to d2 he played rook
captures on g7 right away and now now
morphe gets his chance rook captures on
g7 rook to c3 now
threatening rook to g3 to attack the pin
piece uh but now morphy finds the only
move that doesn't lose the game for him
i'm still considering uh whether i
should have made this pause the video
moment or not but i'm gonna do it i've
decided now while i was recording that
i'm going to do it so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the only
good move for morphe here while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it uh congratulations on finding this
incredible incredible move uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is e3 that's how we do it and
it's such a beautiful move because if we
allow rook to g3 then it's game over
there's no there's no defending this but
now after e3 there's really no way to
tackle this move because well if the
queen captures then you no longer
defended the knight on c4 if the rook
captures you still no longer defend the
knight on c4 and that's a problem and
the queen keeps an eye on the e8 square
so rook captures does not do anything
the queen covers the 8th square
so what can you do here well anderson
now doesn't have a way out he has to
play queen to f6 and settle for a draw
for example e2 we're gonna play queen to
f8 to check and now we just repeat moves
but anderson already down two points not
interested in a draw anderson plays well
queen captures an e3 is still playable
but he plays rook captures on e3 he
wants to keep winning chances alive but
now there simply aren't any uh morphy
plays rook captures on c4 there's no
rook to e8 to check morphe is covering
that so you know there's
not much you can play queen to f6 is
played still you could maybe get a drop
by perpetual here but now you know
avoiding all of the drawing lines and
trying to win the game uh anderson in
the end loses the game rook to c1 check
now the queen has access to the f4 pawn
king the h2 and now queen captures on f2
and he was on f4 and he was in this
position on move 42 that adolf anderson
resigned in the game and yet another
victory for paul charles morphy making
it his third victory in a row uh so
definitely the match starting to go his
way so here it doesn't matter what you
play if g3 queen f2 is checked if rook
to g3 we're gonna capture uh the the
rook not a problem um
sorry if rook to g3 we're going to
capture here with checkmate and if g3
queen f2 is checkmate
uh so yeah really really outstanding
stuff and it was a very enjoyable game i
hope you guys enjoyed that
little uh history behind the eighth
remove why anderson chose it and well he
really got a lot out of it he got a very
very nice attack happening and he could
have uh seized the moment few times uh
you know during the game but he didn't
and in the end he had to start avoiding
draws and you know it was enough for
morphe to win the game but understand
definitely outplay morphe uh with this
a3 idea and we'll see what happens uh
later on in the match because uh
anderson will employ it two more times
during this match with morphe so yeah
once again hope you guys enjoyed it
sorry for a bit of a longer video but we
had to you know properly explain
everything so hope you enjoyed that as
well and the extra pause the video
moment and congratulations to everyone
who found all three of them uh that's
you know just amazing
i would like to thank henry wilson
marshall ferrier julian chun uh francis
ayer and mikhail
mukherjee for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day